This video is brought to you by Squarespace run websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the go to platform to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business.
Jack House Squarespace through that link in the description below more on them
in a bit,
The cold war between the United States and the Soviet union was one of the most
complex and long-lasting chapters of tension between two countries in all of
human history.
From the time world war two ended until the Soviet union dissolved in 1991,
both nations held worldwide nuclear devastation in their hands while the two
vaguely fought for the same side to defeat Germany and the other access powers
in the second world war.
Very soon after the struggle to lead the world politically became a source of
contention,
Russia and America started to obsess over learning each other's secrets.
They started Wars against each other secretly with other neighboring countries,
and they even infiltrated some of the most clandestine intelligence
organizations known to man.
John Anthony Walker was a United States Naval officer enlisting in 1955 and
serving in what most thought was a faithful capacity until 1985.
When it was revealed that it was part of aspiring for the Soviet union for close
to 20 years,
the level of sensitive information he gave away to what the world considered
America's enemies was incredibly detailed and wide ranging,
especially in regard to submarine capabilities and locations,
which was something Walker specialized in during the investigation,
it was found that the spiring he was involved with was operating at a high
enough level to literally change the balance of power between the U S and the
Soviet union, and even his own son was involved in the espionage.
Let's look today at the story of John Anthony Walker and how he got lured by
temptation of power, even when it means betraying his own country.
[Inaudible].
And Sonny Walker was born on July the 28th of 1937 to an Italian American mother
and a father who was a film marketer for Warner brothers as the middle child.
He was raised for a time in Washington,
DC spending his time as an older boy in the local Catholic church.
But the family soon moved to Scranton Pennsylvania. After his alcoholic,
father went bankrupt and lost his job.
The small Pennsylvania town was near John's grandparents.
And while there he took on a paper route,
Asha does a local movie theater and hands hawked home products door to door.
His business acumen enabled him to purchase his own car. At the age of 16,
two years later,
John Anthony Walker made the fateful decisions to join the Navy.
This was not a completely voluntary decision. However,
Walker had recently dropped out of high school and skin,
and the friends had undertaken a slew of burglaries on may the 27th, 1955.
The total whole amounts of do a few tires,
some automobile accessories and a little bit of cash,
but it was enough to get him in the kind of trouble that ended with a police
chase and his eventual arrest, his choice.
Well in list of base jail,
he signed up and became a radio operator serving on a destroyer escort and then
transferring to a full-time crew member aboard the USS Forrestal.
This was no small feat as the forest.
All that was the first American super carrier and it's considered the finest in
its class. In 1957, Walker was on shore leave near Boston.
When he met Barbara Crowley at a dance who would very soon become his wife
within the next three years, they would have three daughters.
Walker went off to qualify at submarine school rising, even higher in the ranks,
but at home things were less than perfect.
It was already resenting having married Barbara and sometimes referred to his
daughters as.
He chose to hang out with his shipmates spending time as a husband and a father
at home. Barbara was desperate to keep him and had another child this time,
that boy John was away at a baseball game instead of with Barbara at the
hospital. So she named him Michael, instead of John Walker.
The third is as part of the wanted still John progressed in his career as the U
S submarine fleet was modernizing in an astounding way.
He was given more and more responsibility.
Walker was given top-level cryptographic clearance and past stringent mental
health tests.
That assured he was capable of being trusted with nuclear weapons in submarine
missions to come far and wide from surveillance missions,
near Russia to nuclear bomb test observations.
He was then assigned to the USS Andrew Jackson.
They high-powered top of the line nuclear submarine in Charleston,
South Carolina. This sub was capable of hitting targets, almost 3000 miles away.
Something the Navy was very proud to admit.
And that's when Walker was granted access to a top secret report that showed
every nuclear target. The United States was considering almost immediately.
John Anthony Walker began to wonder just how much he could gain from sharing
this information with America's enemies.
Wallin in South Carolina.
No Walker attempted to live a fantasy life of luxury. He opens a bar,
which he was sure would be a hit with all of his Navy buddies,
whom he was still carousing around with. Instead of living a more domestic life,
he was developing an alcohol problem,
much like his father had in the past and running a bar was exactly what he
didn't need.
He was able to get the place started with the financial health of his brother
author, who was also stationed in Charleston and who was also in the Navy almost
instantly. He began hemorrhaging money.
He started taking his troubles out on his wife even more and having affairs with
other women, Barbara,
feeling the weight of his distant coldness initiated in a Farah of her own with
Arthur who had a marriage of his own, this dalliance,
which allegedly go on for over a decade with John being none,
the wiser that his own brother was betraying him. The Navy would call upon.
John's a report to one of its prized fleets in Norfolk, Virginia.
And it would turn out to be, yes.
Another major wall placed between him and his wife.
Barbara decided that she could stay in Charleston with the children and help
manage the Bob. They made a deal. The tip, the ball,
wasn't turning a profit within a year. They would sell it,
walk his promotion to Norfolk and rank promotions. At chief warrant.
Officer allowed him a peek into a whole new level of sensitive information.
It was also around this time that his demeanor towards the Soviet union cooled
quite a bit.
It began to thing that the country was not as insidious and fearful.
His fellow Americans believe the assassination of John F. Kennedy in 1963,
cemented these use for him.
He believed it to be the work of the government to continue to inspire fear in
its people, walk us out the Fosse of the cold war and the absurd war machine.
It spawned was an ever-growing pathetic joke to me.
He eventually took the fateful step that would define the rest of his life.
At this time, he stole a classified document in October of 1967,
Walker first took advantage of his top level position at the Atlantic fleet
submarine headquarters to copy an important documents.
This classified information revealed a key list for cracking codes that the U S
Navy used to scramble its radio transmissions. With this information,
the Soviets could learn submarine positions when an advance and all sorts of
other devastatingly crucial information. Once he stole a copy of the documents,
he traveled North to DC, where he made a stop at the Soviet embassy.
He met with security specialist, Yakov,
Luka severed SU was understandably confused at this Naval officer who stood
before him offering to give up the government secrets in exchange for
compensation, Yakov was leery, but contacted a KGB friend of his bar.
A solid Matton's verify that the information was indeed legitimate.
They were both concerned that it was just too serendipitous that someone would
come to them with a winning lottery ticket. It was too easy.
No one comes into a rival embassy stating that they have national secrets that
they want to give to the enemy country. Except John Anthony Walker apparently.
Well, the Soviets lessons,
the Soviet embassy wins often that's in his documents and we're quite pleased
with what they found it revealed. They told him that they wanted more,
much more.
They asked what he expected it in written walk us that he just wanted money.
The embassy and KGB agents grilled him further to see how committed and,
and trenched in the surveillance world he was.
They wanted to know his marital status.
And if he had a history with drugs and alcohol,
the questions about alcohol may have gotten him riled up or hit home too much.
As he quickly fired back with an offer to work for the Soviets for the rest of
his life.
Walker's requests for financial compensation were a little different than the
Soviets were accustomed to. However,
what he was asking for was basically a steady paycheck.
And since the information he had access to was assumption, importance.
They acquiesced Booker threw out a figure of a thousand dollars a week,
and they actually agreed to it.
They forged a deal where they would give Walker a list of code keys.
They desired and he would steal them.
Then a veritable spy movie scene would take place where Walker would have a
folded magazine cover under one arm while parked outside a strip mall.
A man approached him and gave him instructions on how to hand off the valuable
Intel. Once the handoff took place,
he was handed an envelope stuff with money and then ushered off bond,
unknown men before being dumped in a nondescript residential neighborhood miles
away.
John Anthony Walker was now making money as a bonafide Soviet spy.
Now I promise this is not a good way for you to make money,
but maybe starting a business is,
and that brings me to today's sponsor Squarespace. Now, a couple of things,
maybe you've got an idea for a business sense.
You want to see if it's going to work in the world. Well, too,
the only way to know if its going to work is to get it out there.
And the best way to do that is with a website.
And that's where Squarespace comes in.
Squarespace allows you to create a powerful website for whatever you're up to
want to sell something online. Yes.
It's easy to set up a store with Squarespace. Want to start a podcast,
starting a YouTube channel. Well podcasts, of course,
they handle all of that stuff. And if you've got a YouTube channel,
you're going to want a website to compliments it.
It all starts on Squarespace with a beautiful template that you can customize
your heart's content, or you can start from scratch,
or you can easily move over from an existing domain,
making everything super easy to manage. Don't start from scratch.
Just use a template, no excuses.
And it's once you've gone through the super easy customization process,
there are no updates. There's no patches. There's no tech DS to deal with.
Then Squarespace also handled all of the website stuff like I say, podcasts.
Oh yes, but also mailing lists,
social integrations and much more plus 2,400 customers. The board,
just in case you get confused, but you probably weren't. It's really easy.
Had to squarespace.com for a free trial.
And when you're ready to launch go to squarespace.com forward slash buyer
graphics,
and you'll save 10% off your first purchase of a website or a domain,
and let's get back to.
[Inaudible].
So the kids now had a working relationship with Walker.
They still were incredibly careful to make sure that prized cow continued
producing results.
They had KGB agents and former Soviet general early ag collagen assigned to keep
track of walk-up collagen was the man responsible for scoping out the best areas
around Washington DC. Once he scouted an area,
Walker would arrive and cash and intelligence would be traded and literal
countries would inch even closer to nuclear conflict case in 0.1,
such handoff of sensitive military information in 1968,
resulted in the USS Pueblo splice ship being captured by North Korea.
The American Naval ship was then aerated. And the contents sent to Moscow.
The Russians went are deep and American armed services territory.
And most of it was thanks to John Anthony Walker Walker,
whether he knew all of the direct consequences of his actions or not was living
the high life.
He moved to barber and his four kids into a magnificent housing complex in
Norfolk and were spending lavishly despite Russian warnings not to raise
suspicions.
He hired someone to manage his bar back in Charleston that Barbara had been
looking off to the state of that business was still dire and the place was
losing money faster than anyone had anticipated,
but that was just a blip on Walker's radar.
He was simply making too much money to carry on. Notice.
He bought a luxurious sportscar into a huge boat and was shacking up with young
college girls on weekends, even sailing his boat to the Caribbean islands.
Barbara was shocked. However,
when she was going through John's things one night and found some rather
clandestine photographs and written instructions from the hands of KGB agents,
she sat her husband down when he got home and demanded to know what he had
gotten involved in. Surprisingly he, her more surprisingly,
she was intrigued drool.
He was now pulling off acts of worldwide espionage exposed, new,
amazing nuclear submarine technology and changed the way troops at the ground in
Vietnam. Barbara talks about wins and joining John on his next Intel draw.
She credited the slow and painful decline of their marriage to making such a
risky decision and thought somewhere deep down that if she tried to enjoy a
little bit of the spy life too, maybe it would rekindle things with Kapil.
And it might've for a time.
John would be behind the wheel of the car and the two would head off to the
drop-off site with Barbara at ready to jump out and make the swab.
Barbara would even on the wrinkled voted cash. When they got home,
they used an array of tiny cameras and all the Intel they provided to the
Soviets had to fit inside of a soda can,
but the KGB had warned John from the beginning, not to divulge anything,
especially with this family would always come back to haunt him around 1969.
John began being pulled to the West coast as more and better work was opening up
for him in San Diego.
He was to become a mentor of sorts teaching new radio operators,
but that didn't stop him from his thieving treacherous ways.
Since he didn't have the same kind of top level access that he did back East,
you have to rely on a library of classified information to pull from,
which was riskier and more laborious buff. He made it work.
He was becoming a seasoned deft, criminal,
even forged his own security clearance certification.
When he was able to abscond from the San Diego facilities with national secrets,
he had a complex web of Marine gone security checkpoints to navigate.
It was getting harder and harder to cheat on his country.
[inaudible] his pay was changed to reflect the lessening Intel.
He was able to steal bots. He did have an idea.
John befriended a students of his,
that the radio operator training school named Jerry Whitworth. One night,
they went sailing together and he got talking about the recent movie.
Easy rider runs.
The tour began waxing philosophical about making a boatload of money off one big
heist walk. You could tell he already had his hooks in Jerry,
but he waited for years.
John was reassigned somewhere out to see where he could get away from the
family. He didn't want, he had renewed security clearance,
which the Soviet spies loved Barbara began hinting that she wanted to divorce.
But John chums Erin's a remaining in the marriage,
mostly because she could expose him.
So he caught her loose from the spiring and didn't this div Jerry Whitworth.
He turns allianced him with fantastic amounts of money that he could be making,
which with showed some hesitation.
When Walker finally told him it would involve selling secrets to the Russians.
This gentleman calmed him down and said they would also be helping some American
allies like Israel, which Wirth was the perfect foil to,
he had just graduated from the school,
walk a tort and was shipping off to work with satellite communications,
which was its own treasure trove of secrets waiting to be has with Jerry taking
on so much work. Walker moved back to Norfolk and retired from the Navy.
He also finally bid Barbara farewell as the two divorced in 1974.
John's owns to private detective gigs,
but we're still very much under the thumb of the Soviet spiring,
which Wirth was conducting the bulk of the espionage.
But Walker was still doing the drops still, which Wirth was aware of the value.
He was it and began to complain about his lack of compensation.
Walker was already thinking of ways to add to the spiring and began to look to
his own family. His own brother, Arthur joined,
and his began stealing classified documents.
John also began to recruit and talk his youngest child, Michael,
into a life filled with spy adventures. And as Michael adored,
his father had already decided to join the Navy.
John Anthony Walker employed a brilliantly cruel methods to talk his son into
officially spying against the United States.
He brought up one of Michael's favorite movies, the godfather.
I'm going to make him an offer.
He spoke fantastically about how Michael could take over the family espionage
business, just like his namesake did for the Corleone family.
He even showed Michael his social security card noting that Michael's first
three numbers of his card were double Oh seven, like James Bond himself,
Michael was drunk off the fantasy.
Michael was assigned to the USS Nimitz in 1984,
a state-of-the-art aircraft carrier during his time that he was given the
responsibility of destroying sensitive classified material,
being John Anthony Walker's child, though,
you can guess what he did with that information in stat as right.
He stole them and had his father turn them over to the Russians.
You also cracked safe combinations and tried to shake out every single secret
that the ship had contained within it all for his fava Barbara was finding out
more and more after the divorce that she simply didn't want to know about.
He also wasn't paying alimony despite being flushed with cash.
Barbara was not as blessed financially and was actually staying with us on
Michael and his new wife,
her anger towards her ex-husband spilled into the house.
And Barbara begins telling Michael that she might just rat drawn out to the
federal governments. John used this to his own advantage,
telling Michael that he should tell his mother that he himself was involved in
the spiring. John figured that she would never hurt her own son,
even if he was guilty of treason. Of course,
John was just trying to protect himself.
The thing is like we never told his mother about his own involvement.
So without that knowledge,
Barbara did indeed contact to the Boston FBI office and is often much digging
that enough reasons.
John's phones weeks of surveillance ensued and not a lot was gained.
One may day in 1985. However,
while the FBI was secret becomes outside John Anthony Walker's house,
they finally had paid at Walker was inside putting together a hell of a drop for
the KGB, with names and locations and everything else they could want inside.
When he left to do the handoff,
they followed him after losing him for several hours,
they spotted his van more curiously nearby.
They also observed to sit down with diplomatic plates, belonging,
to a member of the Soviet embassy.
The agents pounced on the drop and all the secrets had held.
John Anthony Walker was arrested at a nearby hotel.
His son was still aboard the USS Nimitz, but he too had his cup of blown.
He confessed almost immediately.
Jerry would foolishly let agents search his trailer and they found a computer
disc chock full of things that you should not have had in his possession.
The whole ring was annihilated Walker agreed to testify against Whitworth.
And in return,
Michael was given a more lenient sentence of 25 years and it was released in the
year 2000, the rest of the gang, or received life sentences.
John Anthony Walker died in prison in 2014.
And while the cold war came and went,
he brought the two sides so much closer to all out war than they should ever
have been in the first place so much for being a true countrymen.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Do not forget to subscribe brand new videos,
just like this several times a week. Also please do check it off.
Fantastic sponsors, Squarespace linked to do below. And thank you for watching.